how's the girlfriend speak welcome to
another Indian eyes about did you catch
any oh that this game is called video
game good game
major season junior warning a guy all
right breast be careful you yes gun kill
this guy kill that guy I am coin [ __ ]
hey explode okay okay more coins go guys
more gun more Dargaville everyone
yelling boy upgrade upgrade upgrade
world is [ __ ] high it - bubble that
you everything I'm shooting everyday how
do i commentate over there get my
[ __ ] back game over what yeah I need
more I need more of that fix oh my god
that was amazing Oh show me [ __ ] I liked
the part when it said boobs
all right we're playing race fun racing
we end it up hey where's the cook
where's the cars what is this oh my god
this is better than my record who needs
cars anyway this is genius oh I got a
bomb all right I got ah ah shot what
happened I was naked that's what
happened
Oh God oh no oh no ha ha ha oh my god
motivation it's a game about motivating
a tree go tree hail the mighty tree
hell they my to go tree grow grow grow
go I bought some hair I've had some
friends
Sugoi reach for your dreams keep doing
it friends keep motivating that tree why
am i enjoying this game so much I don't
know haha that is one beautiful tree
all right we're playing when pigs fly I
have a pig fly amazing back to the
drawing board let's put a box on him in
the
but yeah I don't see how this intricate
design could not work all right let's
fly piggy yes
no damn it
you son of a pig back to the drawing
board pigs can fly they said well I'll
show them all right this piggy doesn't
fly I don't know what to do
go pig you're not even moving you're
kidding me Oh get more leaf blowers oh
god damn it let's pick a shell fly if
it's the last thing I'll ever do you all
right piggy go for you go piggy he's
flying he's flying hey piggy yeah at
least the plane is flying Jesus piggy
flower reach in the stars above
ah ah come on come on come on mate come
up okay I guess I need more leaf blower
oh it flew for like a second Oh piggy
now this is what I'm talking about
damn it it's all right we can still do
it no we're dead Mayday Mayday Ren is
gone and it's gone well I guess pigs
just aren't meant to fly huh all right
beat the meat I do that [ __ ] every day
I'm I mean let's play
best game ever oh my god
Ready Set I like I walk around with my
little professed aah
what am i doing aah did you start who
threw that
I just gotta survive for one more minute
ah bull [ __ ] me then no my brofist it
fella
ha ha ha oh my god alright I got I got I
gotta make it it can't be that hard
ah yeah this game it's fences to [ __ ]
out of me now ten more seconds five four
great
doh what oh yeah oh my god yes oh my god
those amazing boy woodbridge minutes get
waiting oh yeah oh god I'm tripping out
I knew I should have snorted that edgers
poof I'm not tripping I'm not tripping
I need more balls to trip Emmy balls I
need to trip them what has been seen
cannot be unseen poop him up amazing
can't wait to play the poofiness begins
how do I poop yeah
gosh oh yeah you've been satisfied whoo
take your pie triple turning it's happen
am i popping myself no it
Oh satisfaction eat [ __ ] tonight yeah Oh
laxatives diary of do
I was born to do this
dammit I might've diarrhea I press
that's all the time I had for today hope
you enjoy watching if you did leave like
and there thank you for hanging out with
me today as always stay awesome bros